[Music]
[Applause]
not only won a super bowl won the mvp
nfl offensive player of the year
the rams cooper cup joining us on the
program were you better football player
basketball player in high school
was a better football player basketball
player
i was a better football player
i thought you were all state didn't you
guys win the state championship as well
uh yeah we did that's a it was a you
know a combination of having some really
good uh some really good uh basketball
players around around me but yeah and i
think i was i don't think i can make an
argument about being a better basketball
player
when did you realize you could play in
the nfl
uh you know dan i i really believe that
back uh when i was nine years old first
time stepping on football field that's
really when it started for me where i
believed right then is like not only i
just believe that was what i was gonna
do that was just to me that was just
what uh i was created
to play the game and
from that moment i was just there was
never a doubt in my mind this is just
what i was gonna do yeah but you walk
off the field after your final high
school game you don't even have a
scholarship offer that kind of hard to
believe you're going to be
super bowl mvp
yeah you never know you walk off the
field you don't know what your next
steps are going to be you don't you
don't know how you're going to get there
necessarily there's definitely uh you
know that doubt wants to creep in a
little bit but uh
the
i just knew there was gonna there was
gonna be a way you're gonna find a way
to make your way there was just uh it
was i just i just believed in my heart i
don't know it's hard to hard to explain
with words um
but that's always going to be what i was
going to do how much trash talking do
you hear
uh trash on it i mean it's part of the
game right i it's just uh it's part of
how you play this thing and um but what
are the in-n-outs what do they say to
you what they say to me yeah uh it was
much worse my first few years has
definitely died down in the
recent
recent history uh but uh it's nothing
too bad you know nothing nothing nothing
too bad but nothing i'd like to repeat
on there oh
but the first couple of years they got
to be really roughing you up because
they're thinking you know who are you
you know probably calling you edelman or
you know i don't know yeah
yeah you know the angle yeah it happens
a little bit but it happens a little bit
but it's not it's not it's not bad you
know it's something you deal with but
you uh you move on with it okay but how
do you what do you say back to these
players
i don't talk i'm not i'm probably you
heard me miked up i'm probably more on
the i fall under the andrew luck
category i'm probably just too nice to
people and um anyone that talks i don't
really say anything you know our coach
talks about nameless like you're playing
against nameless and faceless players
you know you go out there you do your
job
help them up and go uh go do it again
best defensive back you played against
this past year was who
uh not including uh
on my own team yeah non-teammate yeah
okay um
man there's there's some good ones uh
there are some good ones some guys that
challenge you know i thought there's
there's a few guys that i thought uh
you guys might not get as much
you know credit or respect whatever you
want to call it um i thought kenny moore
uh the nickel that we played he plays
for the colts i thought kenny moore was
a really good nickel he did some really
good stuff um i thought you know early
on we played against uh jalen johnson
with the with the bears i thought he was
a guy that would come up and challenge
you and we had to have a plan for him um
and there's a
lot of guys i i could go through but
those two off the top of my head those
two kind of stick out um as guys that i
knew
were
you know were challenging you know
playing and play out
i know you're from washington and steve
largent was one of the best route
runners i ever saw
it feels is there still a place for if
you run the route correctly
that you can get open that it's not just
athleticism speed down the field it's if
you run those routes correctly you
should be open
yeah i think that's uh i mean at the end
of the day we know as a receiver you
know where you're
where you're going the dvd doesn't um
you say you should in theory always be
you know a step ahead of wherever the db
is going um i think correctly is a it's
a broad statement because uh i think you
know you could run a route correctly but
based on whatever you know coverage
you're getting whatever technique you're
getting from the db it might not be the
correct way to run that route versus
what you're being presented so there's a
give and take to that
that i think is important it's it's
running it correctly for the given
situation
we're talking to cooper cup the uh mvp
of the super bowl what did matthew
stafford say in the huddle before that
game-winning drive
do you remember anything
yeah well i mean i think it was just
well you know let's go right now it's
just the belief like hey this is going
to be the drive we go down here we put
points up we're gonna go win this game
so um we've been we've been so stalled
out you know we've been struggling for a
while now and with that with that
offense we were just not able to get
anything going so it was just his belief
even from the sideline hey this is gonna
be the one we're gonna get something
going here if people someone's gonna
make a play um and we're gonna get some
uh some momentum and drive down and you
know put this team up that ball is in
the air
i don't know how long it felt like it
was in the air but what are you thinking
if you make that catch you win the game
yeah it's uh i honestly in the moment
you're not
you're not thinking about anything
in particular it's like you're just in
that moment you're in that moment living
that moment out as a single play in the
football game um you know looking back
on it i mean i know if i had if you had
told me going into the game there's
going to be this moment to try to win
the super bowl um you know there would
have been that like you would you'd
immediately feel the pressure
but for me it was just about being in
that moment right there right right then
being completely present what i had to
do um in that moment was asked of me as
a receiver
and just doing my job to the best of my
ability it wasn't about anything outside
of what the moment really was it was
just uh it was just living in that
moment right there who got the game ball
from the super bowl
you know i don't know i didn't get into
the locker room until things had died
down after i didn't get to hear any of
the like the
celebration or the speech or i don't
know if there was a speech so i don't
know who even got the game ball
who cares more about how they look sean
mcvay
or you
uh
uh
who cares more i i think you gotta go
with sean i think sean cares a little
bit more about how he looks
i like to look good he likes to look
good but i think in terms of who cares
mario i think i can get i can get go out
walk out the door with some shorts and a
t-shirt i think i think sean takes a
little more time in the morning he might
comb his hair at halftime cooper
no he does i'm sure he does i'm sure
he's
i know for a fact he's got to go in at
halftime and the first thing he does is
go look in the mirror okay hair's still
looking good i got my you know what i
got this secret pack of hair gel that he
needs to be anything he's out of out of
place but uh
yeah i'm gonna go with sean that one he
might he might not agree but you can say
it now you were super bowl mvp you're on
scholarship the rest of your life there
um do you expect aaron donald to be your
teammate this year
are you planning on i do okay i
i expect him to be back i mean i i uh
he's he's so good it's hard to imagine
him not being back here with us um you
know going out there and trying to
achieve a
you know winning a super bowl again so
are you taller than him by a lot
i'm not taller than by a lot i think uh
maybe by
a little bit but he's i mean i guess he
is he is uh you see he's a little bit
shorter than how you think he would be
but
um
but you know he's not walking around
he's a he's a big character that walks
around our facility so you know you
don't see him as a you know see him as
being a little shorter what do fans say
to you on the street
uh usually they ask if i am cooper cup
or if like okay sorry your name is your
name cooper
um
because i just i don't know i think i
probably walked around like uh looking
like a normal dude so um
but it's i mean it's cool i believe i've
had some great interactions with fans
here in l.a and just just around and um
yeah everyone's for the most part been
pretty respectful but you don't get
mistaken for somebody else since it is
hollywood
is he are you are you saying anyone in
particular no no no i was just curious
i'm just curious
the
the paul brothers comes up sometimes you
know the situation
similar haircut okay situation okay um
so that comes up sometimes but uh
other than that no not really oh i could
tell that you thought uh oh is he gonna
see it i'm glad you brought it up i was
like i know where this is no no no i i i
just asked i did not know the the answer
to my question there uh tell us who
you're uh representing today
yeah so i'm here with pat today um
they've just been uh they're a an algae
um
really using paddy once daily relief
extra strength has been an incredible
thing for me um talk about having the
right tools for the job that is
something that for me waking up in the
morning boom one drop knocks out my eye
allergies and not having to worry about
you know have you ever tried to catch a
ball with your eyes closed then it's a
it's a difficult thing to do when you
can't see what you're trying to catch so
that's just been the right tool for the
job for me and uh really appreciate the
partnership have you had allergies
during a game
uh no thankfully during a game we i've
been able to get things under control
and uh you know that's why i mean the
issue a lot of times is in the spring
it's in like training camp it's in otas
where i just get absolutely wrecked um
and uh
the best thing has been just being able
to drop these eye drops in there knocks
it out and having to worry about that
for 24 hours has been huge
you're allergic to dropping passes is
what you're allergic to yeah
i had you dropping this great that's a
great line do you know how many you
dropped
i i'm not sure how many i dropped i was
too many i know i know it was too many
five
i think okay well i think we might have
different different uh definitions of
what a drop is what's your definition of
a drop how are you how are you going to
define it however the nfl defines oh
they got you yeah they yeah i usually go
on if you if you touch it if i think if
i touch the football to me it should be
caught
maybe file a grievance here that do you
want to object to those five drops that
you well actually you're trying to add
to i'm trying to add
i'm probably i'm probably not as uh
generous on giving myself a pass on some
of those things have you heard from
jerry rice after your season
and since it sort of been compared to
jerry rice's great season or megatron or
randy moss did any of these former
receivers reach out to you
uh no i mean i think over social media
um possibly some some guys can reach out
and said thank you i think it was
probably during the season and um you
know it kind of gets lost in a shuffle
but uh
you know i i know there's some of those
guys have have reached out and just been
i've been i mean i'm so thankful for the
fraternity we have in the nfl um and
just among receivers too
it's just been incredible to see the
guys that have been playing this game
have played the game for a long time
done some incredible things how much
they root on and are fans of the game
the guys are doing it now and are coming
after them it's a it's a pretty cool
thing to be a part of those are big
numbers
those are those are historical numbers
like what do you do for an encore
i go and try to do my job a little bit
better i think that's so that's what it
is and and then it's really not about
trying to chase the numbers because
that's uh i think that's a slippery
slope that you just don't want to get
into
but for me it's it's about being a
better football player what can you do
to be a better football player the
numbers all that stuff that's going to
end up there's there are so many
variables there's so much that goes into
you know what the end of the day
production on paper is going to look
like but for me i want to watch the tape
and say hey look you know
how can i be that much better playing
and play out how can i you know
you know how can i
move the needle for our team in the
right way um play and play out and that
that to me is where my focus is if i can
do that i can be a better football
player if i can be a part of us winning
more games regardless of what the
production is i feel like i will have
done my job
paulie how many catches is cooper cup
behind jerry rice on the all-time list
jerry cooper's got 433 so he's
1116 catches me you can you can do it
yeah
jerry played 20 22 years yeah
will you be able to put how long will
you play like what do you say to your
wife of
this is the ballpark figure
yeah well i wanna play as long my boys
love i right now i've got a
three-year-old or about to be a
four-year-old one-year-old they love you
know coming to games watching the
football being a part of that stuff i i
think that's only going to get more fun
for them as they get a little older
but as long as they're enjoying it i'm
going to keep playing so you know i
don't really have a cap on it i just
want to
keep going as long as i possibly can as
long as my family is enjoying what's
going on as well um and and as long as
i'm enjoying it as well
um i'm gonna keep playing wearing a
dodger hat
are you a dodger fan or you just like
the hat
i really like this hat you know being
down here i've actually you know started
i've been to a few dodgers games and i
met some of those guys so i'm a fan of
what they're doing obviously doing some
really good stuff playing well this year
um so you know i i had to take a hiatus
from baseball i i stopped playing i was
like in eighth grade
stopped watching it completely and it
seems like just recently started to come
on come back a little bit so
you know i feel like i'll just dive back
in with the dodgers
great to talk to you congratulations and
good luck upcoming season cooper
yeah thank you very much then that's uh
cooper cup
the wide receiver for the rams and super
bowl mvp and uh also the offensive
player of the year